for this quiz I want you to fix this
website you'll be trying out calc with
these images but this time I want you to
fit these three images all the way
across the screen each of the three
images will need to be a third of the
available width and there should be a 10
pixel margin between them pop open dev
tools and inside the head you will find
this style tag inside the style tag
you'll see some comments these are the
places where I want you to make some
changes you can find a link to the
website in the instructor notes when all
three images are aligned correctly with
ten pixels between these images a code
will appear on the website type that
code into this box to continue